at 43 katie began experiencing
debilitating symptoms brought on by the
menopause from anxiety to insomnia
working life became a struggle
it was really significant because i was
existing on about three hours sleep a
night you know it's very common a lot of
women suffer with insomnia um and i was
dragging myself into the office
i couldn't concentrate because i was so
exhausted the brain fog you know really
impacted on you know my own ability to
do my job
over the course of several years she had
to leave three jobs
it's the embarrassment around the taboo
of
not wanting to tell your bosses what
you're going through you're worried that
they're going to think they should never
have employed you um or that you know
you're not really fit for purpose so
i i stopped work and it was really
pretty upsetting
katie isn't alone according to new
research 99 of women say their symptoms
have negatively affected their careers
more than half have had to take time off
work and 60 say their workplace didn't
offer any menopause support
professionals are calling on employers
to do more they want to see menopause
treated in the same way as mental health
and maternity schemes
has such a negative impact for so many
women and these women aren't receiving
the right help support and treatment but
their only option is to not go for
promotion to reduce their hours or to
give up work which is so sad it's a
personal loss for them but it's also a
loss for the economy as well and
organizations are hemorrhaging women
katie has made it her goal to raise
awareness around the menopause but
starting conversation is just the
beginning
ultimately change lies in the hands of
employers aisha zahid sky news